[Applause]
[Music]
did you know there is a country in South
America where most of its population are
of Indian origin and where the official
language is English now if you don't
know which country I'm talking about
don't worry because this is one of the
least known countries in the region and
to be fair the media doesn't really pay
that much attention to it so a small
those four countries of the media don't
talk about very much well that sounds
like the perfect ingredients very visual
politics video we are talking about
Guyana an old British colony who didn't
get independence until 1966
interestingly at the moment of
independence both the government and
popular opinion was generally in favor
of turning Guyana into a socialist
country it was this mindset which gave
the country its Pinto s official name
the co-operative Republic of Guyana but
let's focus on the country today diana
is one of the poorest countries in South
America
[Music]
it has crime and violence rates that are
some of the highest in the entire region
and that's saying a lot
in fact if Guyana is known for anything
it would be for its place in the
international supply of cocaine oh and
also for having one of the highest
suicide rates in the world so not
exactly brilliant things now with all of
this information you'd be forgiven for
not being optimistic about the future of
this Caribbean country but they may be
about to get a lot luckier any you own
power these the signs point to Guiana
becoming an oil power for the time being
this more republic with a population of
about 750,000 inhabitants has already
got the attention and dollars of
multinational companies such as Exxon or
Tesco in size after several years
exploring the area on January the 13th
2017 these two powerful oil companies
announced the discovery of what they
think could be one of the most
significant oil and gas reserves found
less decade oil reserves have been found
in deep waters in the steam mantle under
the coastal waters of Guiana early
calculations estimate that the amount of
oil which can be exploited in the
country is no less than 4000 million
barrels and many experts affirm this
could be a much larger quantity so it
seems that this country holds a huge
fortune just off its shorts but the
question really is how much is this all
really worth considering the price of
oil nowadays we are talking about
roughly 200 billion dollars so leaving
other natural resources of size and
considering only petrol this would
result in the equivalence of two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars per citizen
and it's important to note that the oil
reserves could be much bigger than the
early calculation vindicate
now it is true that oil exploitation is
expensive and requires enormous
investment but this could still be the
first step in a new era of prosperity
for Dioner so far the oil companies I've
mentioned ExxonMobil and Hess have
committed to investing 900 million
dollars a year in Guiana over the next
few years the government is investing -
which plans to start exporting oil in
this means Guiana could be on the cusp
of becoming one of the greatest economic
developments that South America has ever
seen
[Music]
yeah Gianna that poor violence country
could become the kind of country which
other people in South America who are
unemployed might look at and think I
want to change my life I want
opportunities I want to go to Guiana
Guiana could become that big hope for
many unemployed South American people
nevertheless before they start hacking
we have to say that it's not going to be
that easy the road ahead is going to be
fought with difficulties conflicts with
Venezuela much of the oil exploration is
happening in areas that have been
claimed by Venezuela and the part they
have claimed is not exactly small Maduro
considers the region known as Guiana at
we burn to be there and this region
represents more than 70% of Guiana
surface
so essentially Venezuela is claiming of
the entire country as their own and as
if it wasn't bad enough another area
which makes up 7% of its territory is
claimed by their neighbors in Suriname
if their neighbors had the way Guiana
would have been carved up and split
between them a long time ago the thing
is this conflict over territory seemed
to have been forgotten for years this
was likely a consequence of the good
relations that the government kept with
Cuba a country that holds a lot of
influence over this part of the world
it was also likely because Venezuela
wanted the support of organizations such
as karakov the Caribbean community of
which Guiana is a member so now you
might be wondering is he on a Caribbean
country or is it a South American
country well it's sort of both
geographically speaking so the country
is in South America but politically
culturally and socially speaking
gianna is a Caribbean country in fact
Guiana was one of the countries which
used to benefit from petrol to reap an
initiative by Hugo Chavez that was
supplying cheap high quality oil to
those countries which were themes France
but it all changed when on May the 11th
of 2005 the left-wing government of the
People's Progressive Party lost the
general elections to a coalition headed
by their new president David Granger a
man who was closer to Washington and who
decided to end once and for all the
claims coming from Venezuela it was at
that moment that the long ignored
conflict to defrost it and things really
started to heat up it's still carrying a
monkey on its back that monkey is the
unbearable burden of an oppressive and
obnoxious claim our land and sea space
now the conflict is in the hands of the
United Nations
so whatever the solution might be if
there is any it's important to be aware
of this threat to the potential
prosperous future of the honor
[Music]
Rachelle's conference another important
risk is the recurrent racial conflicts
in Guyana which is a continuous presence
in the country's media Vianna is a
complex country demographically around
50 percent of its population is of
Indian origin while 40 percent is of
African origin these are two big groups
who are not exactly on the friendliest
of terms in fact the black minority
claims that for years the Indian
majority has obtained privileges from
the government and always got their way
this is triggered recurrence waves of
varna luckily the situation seems to
have improved in fact the winning
coalition governments is quite
multiracial however there is still the
possibility that further internal
conflict will flare up in any case not
only does this new government have an
opportunity to overcome decades of
conflicts once and for all that it's
also being looked to suffice violence
and corruption in the country
something that Gianna's certainly need
in one of the most corrupt countries in
the world according to Transparency
International so the new government has
quite a few major tasks ahead of them
oil exploitation as well as a fight
against corruption and criminality in
the country nothing is if they achieve
their goals Guiana will attract great
attention and may become one of the
richest countries in South America but
this will only be if they use their
resources well the question is will that
happen and it's certainly a big question
so we've given you our opinion here a
visual politics and now we'd love to
know what you think the using gianna
will successfully take advantage of
their newly discovered oil and what
position do you think Venezuela should
adopt as always leave your comments
below and I do hope that you found this
video interesting if you did please do
hit that like button below and don't
forget to subscribe to this channel for
brand new videos every Monday and every
Thursday and if you're looking for
something else to watch right now why
not check out our video on why
Switzerland is quite so wealthy you can
do that by picking let's say yeah and as
always I'll see you in the next video
[Music]